>> Bret: IT HAS BEEN A WHILE
SINCE WE HAVE SEEN THAT
ANIMATION.
THIS WEEK WE LEARNED
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS NAMED HIS
CAMPAIGN MANAGER FOR THE 2020
ELECTION.
WE HAVE LESS CERTAINTY ABOUT THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE TICKET.
TONIGHT PETER DOOCY LOOKS AT
SOME OF THE POSSIBILITIES FOR
THE DEMOCRAT NOMINATION BATTLE.
>> THE EARLY SEARCH FOR A
DEMOCRAT WHO COULD BEAT TRUMP IS
SCATTERSHOT WITH DOZENS OF NAMES
IN THE MIX.
>> WE HAVE BUILT TWO OR THREE
NEW HOTELS.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO NEED
THEM LEADING UP TO THE CAUCUSES.
THERE ARE GOING TO BE A LOT OF
CANDIDATES.
>> THE OBAMA ERA THROWBACKS,
JOE BIDEN'S FIRST AMONG
DEMOCRATS IN A RECENT QUINNIPIAC
POLL.
OBAMA HAS SAID HE THINKS FORMER
MASSACHUSETTS GOVERNOR DUVALL
PATRICK WOULD BE A GOOD
PRESIDENT AND LONGTIME
ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC HOLDER IS
TALKING HIMSELF UP.
>> I THINK I HAVE THE GUTS.
>> THE NEXT CATEGORY, THE
ESTABLISHMENT.
VIRGINIA'S FORMER GOVERNOR TERRY
McAULIFFE TOLD "THE WASHINGTON
FREE BEACON" THERE IS NOBODY
BETTER THAN TO TAKE ON TRUNK
THAN HIM.
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
ISN'T RULING ON A RUN.
ANDREW CUOMO IS TESTING OUT
ATTACK LINES WHILE BORROWING HIS
SLOGAN.
>> WE ARE GOING TO MAKE AMERICA
AMERICA AGAIN!
>> IF THE PARTY WANTS A
PROGRESSIVE, THERE'S PLENTY IN